im oberbayrischen mammendorf hat die
gemeinde diesen verkehrskreisel umgebaut
radler und fußgänger sollen besser
geschützt werden
dafür wurde die mittelinsel auf elf
zentimeter erhöht kosten 18.000 euro
doch durch den umbau wird der kreisel
zum hindernis busse kommen nicht mehr
gefahrlos drumherum lkw und traktoren
müssen mit haarsträubenden manövern auf
die gehwege ausweichen also ist das eine
katastrophe
ich habe schon gesehen dass die busse da
stehen bleiben weil das alles zu eng ist
da drin also überhaupt der kreisel ist
für mich eine katastrophe ein ziel
bürger streichwerte sagen der teuer ist
um die verkehrssicherheit zu erhöhen
beschließt die gemeinde bereits 2009 10
den kreisel in der bahnhofstraße
anzuheben
der grund der alte verkehrskreisel ist
ebenerdig autos fahren einfach geradeaus
drüber oft viel zu schnell eine echte
gefahr für fußgänger und radfahrer kurz
nach ostern 2021 ist der umbau
vollbracht mit drastischen folgen weil
die mitte jetzt 11 cm aus der fahrbahn
ragt müssen lastwagen auf den
bürgersteig ausweichen muss er ebenfalls
weil das viel zu gefährlich ist dürfen
sie nicht mehr durch den kreisel fahren
fünf linien müssen umgeleitet werden
schulbusse können das nahe gelegene
schulzentrum nicht mehr anfahren in
mammendorf ist der ärger groß
also man muss ja vorher bis überlingen
und nicht hinten auch feststellen dass
fahrrinne drüberfahren der dass die
bulldogs und vor allem die schulbus
seine drüber kommen
ich finde einfach nur gefährlich ich
finde der katastrophe jetzt für die
busse die mammendorfer rathaus versucht
man erst gar nicht dass kreisel desaster
kleinzureden schriftlich heißt es die
gemeinde hat die reklamationen von omv
und den landwirten aufgenommen
der bereits getätigte umbau wird
vollständig zurückgebaut
aber von dem ganzen hin und her sind sie
in mammendorf schwer gemerkt dass das
was vorhin planen sollte und dann sollte
das anderen fuß haben und immer wieder
umplanen und immer wieder rum ändern
weil das kurz darauf
schön ist es natürlich nicht als auch
die kreuzung wird jetzt wieder
drei tage gesperrt sein und ich wurde
hinten ja ich komme hier nicht mehr
durch der nächste woche hier wieder die
bagger dann bekommt der kreisel eine
höhe von 5 cm
das kostet nochmal 18.000 euro so sollen
die busse drum herum kommen und die
autos nicht darüber brettern die
mammendorfer sind gespannt ob das dann
funktioniert